[Music]
everyone I'm Lucy I'm Dave top this is
Jeff from the overwatch team I'm Oscar
Oscar who has grown so tired of my joke
I'd stay through the gamescom between
it's our last day here guys all odd face
but we have played a lot of cool games
today to go on day one I like yeah we
played some games today we tried the spy
games comes best efforts I got like
literally trapped in a sea of humans
before what did you go down the shuffle
oh it's playing - you see a human let's
go floor unlike suddenly it just just a
tide of humans is like well was it next
Center brings the games are games I
played pairs which is awesome but no one
wants to work because it's just like
give me like a tweak just like post 2017
but a bit better a bit slower now you
play fifa it's also like the last one
but slower yeah yeah but that one's not
as good whereas this one PES is bad what
makes PES about the people I was just
like more responsive and that's the
classic football game that's just my
thing it's just like it's just better
it's more fun it's more satisfying when
you score a goal anyway it's basically
same so I'm not going to where I'm gonna
talk about absolvo is a 3d fighting game
open-world seamless multiplayer or they
are just throwing game I'm just throwing
genres are you Lucy you're not catching
ourselves of anything you know it's a
bit dark souls it's about solar it's
really hard as I'm rubbish at fighting
games so it's the dark souls of my games
games film but yeah it's like it's this
really complex fighting game where
you've got like four stances and like
basic attacks and special attacks and
some of them change the Sancerre going
into and so on
don't and you can change all of the
attacks they're in each stance and
there's like 180 different attacks I
think they said that you can swap in an
A and then combos on top of that it's
like this thing is deep and it's really
really good it's really pretty as well
despite being like quite a small I think
it's a budget price as well like but I
really enjoyed it despite being not a
huge fighting game found Tom you'll love
it changing its of it and it's coming
out very soon so I'm ready so that's one
of my most eagerly anticipated games
even if someone who doesn't like
fighting games I'm really excited for
that I'll choose their thing
I played battle tech today which has
gyros it's basically XCOM with giant
mech suits
it looks pretty exciting like you play
as a mercenary who's fighting for some
Queen and you've got like a little
ragtag ship you get to hire your own
mech warriors you get to build your own
mech take them into battle and then it
goes from like a scouting phase where
you're like using sensors to see where
the other mechs are and then sort like a
turn-based phase but it's it's got like
it has got a lot of depth to it because
you can do things like blow mechs arm
off obviously they can't use the weapons
on that arm you can do things like jump
next to a mech and start tearing its
limbs off if you hit the cockpit the
pilot gets injured if you hit it in the
back of the courgettes blowing up you
can blow one leg off and it falls into a
puddle and then piss in a puddle it's
more vulnerable and you can target
individual spots it's I was like this is
pretty deep and it's where giant robots
in and it's like on the surface of the
map planet and I get to just blow [ __ ]
up with giant robots
that's like sick all right this is not
technically not usually into these meant
that game
yeah well carries on from the
MechWarrior franchise my xbox game it
was like they said it was the first get
console game to ever have online
multiplayer just continue to on them and
the whole universe is based upon a
tabletop miniature thing Starbucks I
also played after we did a podcast
yesterday I played divinity
I didn't player so I saw a divinity
original sin - yeah that I loved the
original Tiffany Wilson that was a weird
thing to say
- seems to be some really original this
ability little secret repeat incentive
it's Charlotte RPG say you can do
anything but you can't really do
everything well not without original sin
to you I keep I was like looking at
things that I feel like oh I bet I
couldn't do that and since I could and I
always thought it would have the classic
RPG like reins of you can't finish the
main quest if you kill the difficult
character or it's a video original sin -
has because they know players will want
to kill everyone because some people
they're just nuts like that they've
added a mechanic where you can just talk
to their ghosts if you kill the main
quest giver you can be like I'll just
edit up this ghost but then if you kill
his ghost i can kill girl and you like
absorb them for source energy and then
you can't feed aggressors but it's got
so much detail in it
it evens the point where you can get you
can make it a flat plate in coop you can
trick your friend by getting a poison
class pouring the red food coloring a
red dye in it be it like hey a healing
potion for you what should your mate
drink it I'm poison them it's it's
shaping up to be super cool it's been an
early access for a long time and I've
held back because the previous original
sin game I just blitzed in like a week
and it's played nothing but I wanted the
same experience with the original sin -
so I'm waiting for it
early access which is late September I
believe and then me and my badass
barbarian lady lizard and so I pick up
some ass so you wanna see me that week
taking the week off yeah fair enough
well we saw just on a - definitely
outsider which has saved my games car
best game I have played games by a
country mile it's not even a full game
I'm judging by how much was in so we
played it for an hour and it was just
one mission but the thing is you play is
Billy so you play as Rosario Dawson's
character the one well Megan Megan
Foster impossible her name's Billy look
and yeah it's just like - one mission it
but you she can pick up contracts as
well so and then there's like each thing
had a like an optional side to be ups be
enough that you could do if you wanted
to so I got like nowhere in that mission
cuz I was just wandering around doing
everything she has a whole new set of
powers that are unlocked from the get-go
she was gonna be I didn't think she's
gonna be assessing so I was thought she
was armors she's young so they the game
actually takes place in Kanaka again
where she's going to find a knife that
is capable of killing the outsider
because obviously the outsiders
influence has had a detrimental effect
on doubt who's you know mentor and the
leader of the it's ansel bad assassins
no he that's the rude this is they call
him say yeah her powers are really cool
so she's got the traditional movement
ability but it takes a little more like
strategic placement so you don't just
like point and then when you let go the
teleport there you basically place a
marker so like you've looked somewhere
place the marker and then you press the
trigger again and then she like swaps
with the marker and she's got another
Bailey called 4sight which is kind of
like her like
sight of vision thing but it basically
makes her disembodied and she can like
flow around and like small vents and
stuff are highlighted so you can follow
around you through and go into like and
buildings even though you're outside
and you can mark enemies and you can
place one of the kind of like and
markers that you would teleport to while
you're doing that so you can place it in
there and then like teleport back to
yourself like make your way to like a
like within line of sight of it and then
teleport through obstacles that you
couldn't usually do it
it's an incredibly like really cool
power that shows off some of the way
that the levels are designed and I think
it might do it a little better than the
original game itself because you can see
oh yeah there's been see I don't even
know it's that and like I can't water
yeah yeah the power was amazing this is
the one I was like using my whole time
is you can always like you can get the
face of someone and just sort of like
hold it's basically kind like the
mesmerized thing you like people be
attracted to but instead of a big
floating big old thing you have the
person's face so you can walk around and
people will think that you're like
either of God or just a civilian and you
can use that to get into places without
being hassled should become arias back
pretty much she's a faceless and yeah
you can go for as far as you can every
you can stay with this face but if you
move then you're like energy meter
complete but you can get quite far with
it as long as the unconscious body of
the person who you've nicked the face of
is it discovered you think you really
could in theory makes one unconscious
carry them to a vantage point put them
somewhere yeah but you can you can't get
the face of someone who's already had
their face yeah so you'd have to like
grab them and then you take the physical
face or is it magic thing luckily she
like puts her hand over and forms like a
fake version if you don't actually see
their face it's just represent by like a
really weird looking black masters
holding in her hand it's like a
hallucination or vision if you tell
every person has that kind of like
hypnotized look in their eyes okay
it was just like more Dishonored 2 yeah
but more Dishonored it's just everyday
and like yeah the first mission we did
was like you just need to find that
knife find where the knife is and you
have to investigate three different
people and there's so much like within
each house you go to like one musicans
house any like you have to figure out
how to open a lock that's only triggered
by a music so you've got to find the
right music and it's like that classic
it's on a creative mission and puzzle
design set in a world that's really
intricate and like really nice to look
at so yeah it's it's I think it's like
so much to read and it's for an
investigative and new cost like really
helps that because it highlights notes
and stuff that you would miss as well
yeah and it's just like I did find
myself doing that thing where I was just
uh oh I know I've only got now but I do
really want to read like this thread and
see I didn't do that
musical luck thing I went and rescued
it's talking to a journalist who'd been
harassed by members of this gang and he
was offering a reward if I discovered
something else trying to run around and
gather all this evidence for him and
there's a lot to do do you think given a
standalone game from what you've played
so far do you think you could play it if
you didn't play like me
the original dishonored to just the one
coyote players because that I know those
theories that I mean I thought wow he's
yeah I know he is in it and so we don't
know like he's driving you know what's
driving pretty low so who knows maybe
maybe something see any like familiar
areas from because you said it was own
clan tacos I'm I'll be quite interested
to revisit like a level from just on a
two year and with with this new suite of
power is kind of see what else you could
do with it you know it was just like a
it was a new area of conduct it looks
visually very similar but yeah I mean
I'm
nothing like we weren't told whether we
go back to somewhere I imagine it's
gonna be a point where it's like you
need to go back to this point because
they all make sense see more kingdoms I
reckon I reckon Bobby some more familiar
locations there so that was that was our
final day at Gamescom from yeah peace
out well done that's good job everyone
did it go through it if I do tomorrow
we're very good to the pocket but for
more of course from all the big gaming
events across the world not just in
lovely Germany make sure to keep your
eyes peeled to youtube.com slash games
for against welcome our social media
feed for whole shebang peace we have
Boise